welcome to the program we begin with
breaking news from the occupied West
Bank where a major Israeli military
offensive is underway these are live
pictures from Janine where Israeli
forces have killed at least five
Palestinians and injured more than 30
during their operation the Israeli Army
has struck Janine with at least 15
airstrikes another Palestinian has been
killed in Ramallah
the refugee camp in gene is being
targeted it's home to more than 20 000
Palestinians and came under attack in a
major Israeli raid only two weeks ago
seven people were killed then and more
than 100 injured in that operation
the Palestinian Authority called the
latest operation a new war crime against
defense as people Alan Fisher reports
from Janine in the occupied West Bank
it began in the early hours of the
morning the biggest assault in the
Janine refugee camp since the second
interfada are Uprising back in 2002.
[Music]
breaks into the heart of a heavily
populated area in Janine smoke could be
seen rising from residential blocks
the Israeli Army claims it's involved in
an operation against what it describes
as terrorist elements in the area the
Palestinian presidency says the assault
is a new war against the Palestinian
people Janine constantly is attacked by
Israelis now with warplanes and drones
and missiles and they've used uh almost
every Arsenal every weapon in their
Arsenal and the resistance simply keeps
expanding Columns of Israeli military
vehicles could be seen fishing into the
Janine camp
keeping up roads leaving chaos in their
way
drones spotted in the air
the assault coming just hours after the
end of the Muslim Eid holiday brought
protests onto the street
just last month and there's really
attack in the same area killed six
people and led to days of unrest
the Israeli military says it's
strengthening operations across the
whole occupied West Bank and is
preparing for possible missile strikes
from inside Gaza and Lebanon more than
100 Palestinians have been killed in
Janine since the beginning of
2022. the Israeli media described the
area as a wasp's nest because militant
groups have started working together
setting aside their differences coming
under one umbrella Attack Helicopters
have been used in the most recent
attacks in Janine the first time they've
been seen in the West Bank in years Alan
Fisher Al Jazeera in the occupied West
Bank
and Imran Khan joins us live from West
Jerusalem now Imran it's certainly a
dynamic situation in Janine what more
have we learned about these latest rates
well the Israeli Army have issued a
statement it says much as you'd expect
them to say but it does go on to say
something very interesting towards the
end it was from the Israeli Army Chief
spokesman Daniel hilgary he says we did
not come to occupy the refugee camp this
is not an operation against a
Palestinian Authority but Against Terror
groups his words in Janine hagari
branded the operation as a brigade level
rate but didn't give it a name now
normally an operation of this size gets
its name but this just goes to show you
that this is a far larger than we've
ever seen in recent years before against
Janine refugee camp also taking place in
Ramallah as well now it's likely that
this is a response to the far-right
Coalition members people like
bethesulation
the national security minister who are
calling for a massive operation across
the West Bank it's likely that this
operation the size of this operation is
to try and appease those hard right
members of the Coalition it's worth
mentioning at this point that the
Israeli Army the generals have counseled
against that kind of operation but
clearly they are happy to do something
of this nature and it is taking place uh
by land and by air there's use of
helicopter drones uh sorry drones and
helicopter gunships we haven't seen
helicopter gunships being used in the
occupied West Bank since the second
interfada so it is a very large
operation now the Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu has also convened a
security consultation meeting that takes
place at 10 45 in a few hours time it's
likely that at that place that at that
point they'll try and discuss what
happens next but all eyes now are on
reaction particularly from the Gaza
Strip the Israelis have set up a rocket
defense system on the borders with the
Gaza Strip just in case there is any
reaction from there but we've been
speaking to people within uh the Gaza
Strip Hamas have actually said that the
Janine arms of men the fighters there
are more capable of Defending themselves
so although this operation is going on
right now what happens next what happens
in the next 12 24 hours is going to be
crucial
give us a sense of What's led up to this
point Imran these attacks have come amid
escalating violence in the West Bank
well these raids on Janine take place on
an almost nightly basis uh they have
been taking place over the last year but
this is much more of an escalation than
we've seen before what normally happens
is the the Israeli Army go into uh
Janine refugee camp they try and arrest
people they try and uh
take part in what they call targeted
killings on occasion uh perhaps not in
this case but this is a much bigger
escalation and the reason for that is
because the fighters within the Janine
refugee camp have all now come together
and this poses a problem for the
Israelis the Israelis say that this is a
national security threat however there
are dissenting voices within Israel who
say that this just leads to further
escalation that it becomes Tit for Tat
that unless there's a negotiated
agreement with the Palestinian Authority
that the Palestinian Authority come to
an agreement with the gunman then this
escalation will continue and that's
really what we're saying right now but
those dissenting voices are you and far
between by almost an overwhelming
majority there is a desire to try and
take out the fighters within Janine
refugee camp and this is the kind of
operation that we perhaps are going to
see much more of all right thanks so
much for bringing us up to speed we'll
cost back to you throughout the day
Imran Khan in West Jerusalem
and earlier I spoke with Ahmed tabassi
who is an artistic director at the
freedom theater in gene he lives in the
refugee camp there and told us the
current Israeli operation feels
different than previous raids this year
before one hour or another half per year
a big sound a big bomb sound beside the
people I live in front of the Vietnam
but the problem that sniper is all
around the freedom theater and the
buildings around the freedom theater The
Hidden theater wasn't really a Target
but you know we this is the middle of
the relief camp and in the entrances
between camp and therefore make it very
difficult you cannot eat them all the
windows or check what's going on inside
outside from the morning the results are
being destroying uh the streets in
electricity no internet the soldiers
therefore every soldiers shooting
everywhere they're trying to do what
everyone many injured people civilians I
mean and for sure from last night until
now we didn't know the number of Martyrs
or the people who killed through this
time the way it is
today it really brought us back 20 years
for the 20
Invasion the way it is aiming now acting
and doing in the guinea Camp it's very
clear they are not coming to do any
Security operation they're coming to
destroy the camp they're coming to kill
they're coming to destroy they're coming
to a haircut and help our children hurt
our life is a problem as we are inside
the houses we didn't know what is going
on outside we cannot do anything
what survives we didn't cut the cables
everything's been cut so it's more than
an
invasional camera
let's bring in Mustafa baguti who is the
Secretary General of the Palestinian
national initiative and he joins us from
Ramallah thanks so much for being on the
program at Mustafa first of all what's
your reaction to the events of the past
11 or 12 hours
well what we see is another Act of War
crime from the site of Israel and it's
the military army
let me remind you that uh
refugee camp is a highly densely
populated area of refugees who are
displaced by Israel in 1948 in one of
the worst acts of ethnic cleansing these
people also are under Israeli occupation
since 56 years like the rest of the West
Bank
and now the Israeli Army is conduct is
using its own military Arsenal including
F-16 jet fighters Apache helicopters
that throw rockets at the camp
tanks drones
also armored vehicles a whole Army is
attacking civilian population in one of
the most densely populated areas with
refugees who were displaced by this same
Army Israeli Army I think what we see
here is a real world crime that would
not be allowed and it is conducted with
the provocation of ministers in Israel
who call themselves fascists like
smotherich who called himself a fascist
homophobe and being there who have been
calling for a wider military operation
on Palestinians there is no
justification for what's happening no
justification for the fact that Israel
is shooting people injuring them killing
them and then preventing medical
personnel and from reaching the injured
people this is a massacre in every
Dimension and it is happening mainly
because I would say because of the
Silence of the International Community
that has allowed Israel
to conduct ethnic cleansing against
Palestinians the longest occupation in
modern history a system of apartheid and
now acts of killing since the beginning
of this year no less than 190
Palestinians have been killed by the
Israeli Army including 25 children
including a child who is only two and a
half years old this is a war on
Palestinian civilian population and when
Israel says it is defending itself this
is really a joke uh the the largest
military army in the region claims that
it has to defend itself from civilian
population who are under their
occupation yes I want to pick up on a
few things that you've mentioned there
firstly Mustafa we're talking about the
far-right Israeli government a peaceful
resolution given the makeup of the
current Israeli government is unlikely
isn't it
absolutely I mean not only this Israeli
government honestly speaking Israel has
blocked any possibility for negotiations
since Netanyahu came to power in 1996.
let's remember that these extremists are
the ones who killed and assassinated the
attack Robin the one who concluded Oslo
agreement with Palestinians Netanyahu
has been on award track trying to kill
any potential or possibility for peace
and since 2014 they would not even meet
with Palestinian site
Israel is trying to consolidate a system
not only of apartheid and occupation but
a gradual ethnic cleansing and their
immediate they're very clearly declared
Gold by this government is to Annex
lowest bank and exit completely and
Netanyahu said it only a few days ago he
said he will not only prevent the
establishment of a Palestinian state but
he wants to extract from people's minds
the whole idea of the possibility of
two-state solution so Palestinians are
facing here award a series of atrocities
from the Israeli side and we have
nothing to do but to defend ourselves
with every possible every possible form
of resistance as you mentioned this has
been going on for decades now and
there's a new generation growing up
under this occupation how does that
impact the conflict
the younger generation have lost hope in
the Palestinian leadership have lost
hope in the so-called peace process
because they've seen nothing but
expansion of settlements and nothing but
attacks on them and their families and
that's why the younger generation of
course is very angry and this younger
generation now believes that Israel
understands only the language of course
and that if we don't resist we cannot
even defend our lives we cannot defend
our children our you cannot defend our
families but let's put things in
perspective what we are talking here
about are few small number of young
people who are trying to use very
primitive arms sometimes but in reality
what we see here is a civilian
population
of Palestinians who are under Israeli
attack constantly facing the largest
army in the region and facing a fascist
government only fascists in previous
history would conduct a war on own
civilian population who are under their
occupation I really laughed when I heard
what the Israeli spokesman said when he
said that they are not intending to
occupy Union but they are occupying
Janine already since 1967. so they are
trying to mislead the world with a
terrible propaganda the reality here is
that we are facing the worst kind of
atrocity the worst kind of occupation
and a true new war crime that is trying
to repeat what happened in 2002 when
Israel invaded Janine invaded the whole
of the West Bank and I am worried that
they would repeat this same crime also
enables and another area sure and and
Mustafa I just want to ask you one brief
question before we let you go
um the reason I'm rest has prompted
Global concern we know that the United
Nations human rights Chief condemning
Israel's use of heavy Weaponry as you
mentioned but it seems to have made very
little difference what do you want from
the International Community
well I will start from what uh with what
I want from Arab governments I want to
Arab governments to immediately boycott
this Israeli fascist government
I know that words of condemnation and
statements will not affect Netanyahu he
doesn't care about all of that what we
want also from the International
Community is really to start boycotting
this government this fascial government
in Israel and imposing sanctions the
world is using Rebel standards look at
Ukraine they used 11 000 punitive acts
sanctions on Russia in two months here
we are under occupation for 56 years we
are under we we've been subjected to
ethnic cleansing for 75 years not a
single sanction was used against Israel
time has come to impose sanctions in
Israel like the system of apartheid was
treated in South Africa at one point of
time without boycott divestment and
sanction Israel will not listen to
reason and they will continue these
crimes till we reach a very dangerous
point of explosion really appreciate
your thoughts on this Mela thank you so
much for your time Mustafa baguti a the
Secretary General of the Palestinian
national initiative
thank you